[Music]
in production problems news submitted by
the chosen one this is one of new Star
Wars on sono spin-off have been replaced
in the fourth month of production what
did they do they [ __ ] up
well what they switch the director in
the middle of them yeah which is like
unheard of [ __ ] I had to do that with a
Deadpool 2 the second one really I heard
the original directors I [ __ ] this I'm
tired of these [ __ ] like Ryan Reynolds
type jokes I want to do like a legit
film I want to do like with jibt jokes
and then he just bounced out in the
middle of the field oh I think so I'm
surprised it's not blacklisted yeah you
can't just leave in the middle of a job
like that your director sounds like they
just said they won't do any more
no actually you're fine about fired Oh
fire bill Lord and Chris Miller are the
two directors over on this film they are
writing and directing team they've
worked on 21 and 22 just real cool how
do you with the Chance of Meatballs and
the lego movie yeah I like that yeah so
they were hired to direct the Han Solo
spin-off which is still untitled and so
they've been filming since February
there's still several weeks left of
filming but during the filming they
apparently had these creative
differences with the producers this is
what Lord and Miller said quote
unfortunately our vision and process
weren't aligned with our partners on
this project we normally aren't fans of
the phrase creative differences but for
once this cliche is true we are really
proud of the amazing and world-class
work of our cast and crew the basin and
one of the producers I mean Kathleen she
said quote Phil Lord and Christopher
Miller are talented filmmakers who have
assembled an incredible cast and crew
but it's become clear that we had
different creative visions on this film
and we decided to part ways I want to
know the real [ __ ] don't give it out
Hollywood potion I know what happened oh
happy there's one insider though that
did mention that or if they were having
differences understanding the Han Solo
character
so there was this one person that said I
keep not a comedian he's just hot
stickin selfish so it seems like these
directors wanted to you know spin more
jokes and go like crazier with the
character with an actual producers you
have there way more traditional and so
they had like an entirely different
vision for this film so I think kind of
happened like how solar should be funny
and it produces like a [ __ ] pocket
about who will [ __ ] you [ __ ] I hope
your [ __ ] kids hmm no they gets
heated on set though especially when it
comes to like visionary mm-hmm my saying
that's what happened but I'm pretty sure
it was like some [ __ ] you literally
started yeah what is it exactly what
happened I like David's version more I
want to see some Hollywood producers
throwdown
so it's not the directors that split up
if the directors and the producers happy
here so they fired themselves no so it
seems like you fire the producer fired
director from the way that they're
reporting it it's like they kind of got
kicked off the film as the producers
reliable this is our comic we don't like
what you're going with it so we're
kicking you out at it and do that
so they're saying though that now
they've hired Ron Howard oh cool mmm
yeah you still selected what was the
last movie he directed Silence of the
Lambs you didn't see that to me no you
did I just toking if you do Deadpool so
come on Howard
another example all right the last only
directed yeah inferno all right the
difficulties yeah he did that I don't
know Star Wars is one of those really
really like sacred brands that there's a
lot on the line I think it's even more
like the characters or so it's a lot
more crazier than Marvel oh for sure you
just can't take anything you can't mess
it up and I think there's just a lot
more on the line when it comes to yeah
that's like that it's interested like if
you have an opinion about a Star Wars
film that doesn't like match with the
majority could they get so mad
yeah like the recent Star Wars film
where they were you know continuing the
story I thought that movie was a
complete [ __ ] ass which one is Owen
Road one no roboy was a different day
they got to have creative freedom what
that I thought robot was pretty decent
but it's it was so stupid
I didn't see that nice I wanted they
just keep on doing play backs to the
original Star Wars which is completely
fine yeah I mean like they have like the
whole swipes and everything just like
the og stuff which is dope I really
appreciated plan like for example like
they were trying to find the Millennium
Falcon right and then han Solo is just
like it's in the one place in the
universe I didn't check it's like what's
all conveniently you know what I mean
like it's just like it was so stupid
everything was placed it was just kind
of it's not where the girl in the mean
yeah she was dope I really liked her I
do the comedy was so awkward you could
tell those two had like the worst
comedic timing so it made me cringe
there was like really only one part that
was funny and I they kept on trying to
do like this banter between the guy and
the girl what they were supposed to have
funny banter and it was totally flirting
to to a nature exactly but it's super
[ __ ] awkward cuz you could tell
that's not like in their bag of acting
but I'm not saying it like as a critique
point it's just like eat people in the
theater what kind of like all of us were
just like the [ __ ] weird it just it
just wasn't a good film dude and I don't
like it when they paint my childhood
films edited so this you know what's
funny like sometimes there's like heated
ass [ __ ] discussions creatively over
like the cutest [ __ ] like I could
picture like someone like working on Toy
Story and it's like the [ __ ] game
seated over the color of like Buzz
Lightyear's like al-fayed or something
that's been all the time in creatives
like you know and it's like people are
so emotionally invested into everything
like oh no after well you take a step
back and you're like what's a fun that's
stupid
what the [ __ ] was all that about yeah
like where's Lord and Miller they're
saying that they had very limited
creative freedoms or that's the thing
that we agreed on like it freedom
yeah credo credo I like creative I want
freedom as I this this movie is really
stirring up Hollywood like what this is
crazy they're like in the middle of it
and they got rid of the directors and
bringing in some when you come out Ron
Howard is going to spend weeks re
editing and doing pickup shots of what
they've already filmed and then take off
from there but it's like a lot of work
ahead and they're also like not really
sure how I could
going to get it credit like the director
credit and I just Canada restart
everything which money money yeah but
what if there is stunt like 10 million
yeah I possibly win that pocket they're
all rich wait wasn't that virture like
it's if you just think of like they have
a whole creative freedom thing it's
funny like when you allow somebody to do
what they want to do yeah creative when
you allow somebody to do what they want
to do is like the product so different I
feel like I think the director of Logan
right he also did x-men the the second
one second generation isn't [ __ ] like
that I forgot which one it was but it
was pretty terrible but in Logan he
would love do whatever the [ __ ] he
wanted related are create the backstory
and that was the literally probably one
of the only Marvel films I really liked
was Logan oh he was awesome because it
was a standalone film you don't have to
be an x-men event to like that film you
know you just enjoyed it for what it is
I really thought it's too and then like
Logan was amazing they're going to make
it like film no I didn't put a black and
white version of it - well that's time
it's crazy like because they allowed him
to do what he wanted and then it was one
of the best Marvel films that ever came
out I mean obviously what they called
guardian of the galaxy is really funny
but it was more of a serious one yeah
especially in the beginning for saying
that they're cool of that [ __ ] I think
Wolverine should be way more vicious
than what we see yeah is you that's how
his character is like in the comic books
- so what I thought actually didn't read
up on anything about Logan and people
just like yelled dope so when I watched
it there was nobody to theaters and the
opening scene just [ __ ] it puts his
claws right through the head so I was
like oh what the [ __ ]
and I can expect any of that I wish they
would hire me to write the character
story because if Wolverine is an animal
what he should be doing is putting his
mouth so I get like an example he'll be
putting his mouth on someone's eye and
they're sucking the eyeball up and then
use his claws to cut the retinas that's
what that's what should be happy not the
type of action that's what - disgusting
characters to me like to be the
certainly more like stick his hand in
the person's mouth all the way down the
esophagus and then activate his cost
once he reaches his rectum
now from the inside out we'll get
disgusting real that's what he's a
minister of torture I know you want your
old boner you know what I pictured when
you said about the [ __ ] eye thing you
know how like that is if you want to
make egg whites right you just take the
oh your head you suck the egg yolk and
you take it I just pictured that like
looks like a cook an egg yolk going in
if someone's not the stature of the
original Wolverine though original like
it we're on like five everyone
actually the original reppin is posed to
be really short but you're like what
five eight five nine yeah you got like
the muscular build
you actually look like Wolverine movie
lover in I'll hop right entire meets or
no we just got a make a full feature
from the trailers how we met yeah yeah
I came to say goodbye haha trailers all
right little buddy when you slap me
oh that's right that [ __ ] was amazing
take my company Oh Oh what the company
no I don't thank you so what whoa oh oh
god you deeply
yeah I actually want to see like an
entire book recreated by you and just
differently the tortured the thing that
you've never you should call it the
Ministry of torture no play with this
show how do you think of that I love
violent my favorite one was when he got
some of the ears and and you pull the
ears out first of all you have a scrunch
up your body so oh yeah we got in that
position or bad it's what he could
violate but it's also very funny looking
like can you imagine a man going on to
another man's eye and like sucking his
eye out you got a [ __ ] [ __ ] his eye
out first it's like the game that we
played on just kidding party second
glove yeah he's so violent that zone
there's a Korean film called like acaba
de palapa I'm a support act yeah so it's
like it's really a like one of my
favorite revenge films of all time right
and everybody's watching the film and
also with the Korean GI Joe yeah exactly
exactly what's the English translation I
saw the devil I have really good things
about that yeah this dude's is watching
it everyone else is horrified by all the
[ __ ] he's doing that Matt you made merry
oh watch Jake I guess I was just like
yeah enemy no this is no actually yeah
and this was watching the film and he's
like and I was like dude is that [ __ ]
crazy he goes north 20 thing is like
five minutes before was happening yeah
that cuz I'm watching the bullet I'm
like you know what I would do I went to
this school isn't that what happened but
like in that situation when I was like
brainstorming like oh there's a bat here
there's a steak here what what do you do
and I'm like what I do
oh I would grab that and do this and
it's exactly what happens yeah okay
maybe I did there was a guy that was
there's a scene in the film spoiler
alert but
and all the movie it's okay yeah but a
lot of people probably have seen this
one come on your life is like a part
where the guys like no she's like
basically mocking him laughing at him
right he's like well you think that's
funny he grabs his mouth but he stares
his mouth apart you knock him back is
like he's laying in the hospital on my
mat at this [ __ ] talks about it
one more time I will stick my hand into
his mouth and with the plan just locate
their entire job he did other yeah
you're like so basis where we got to be
friends because he was like talking
about is like well because if you're
already here your family's probably dead
your wife's already raped anyways
exhausting laughing its face is it no
you don't say nothing like that to a
human being that's not 9 kind of watch
that felt good
hope you guys enjoyed that episode if
you guys have any juicy little guts of
details and you guys almost admitted
well guess what you can cruise on over
to the description box below click on
the link submit the story and hopefully
we will pick it and talk about it for
more videos click right over here
[Music]